what I'm very interested in is you you
didn't tell me what happened with Kid
Rock the whole Kid Rock situation that
that is technically another L okay well
then great
transition okay so um I was in uh
Madison Square Gardens for uh the UFC
295 love the UFC every time um at the
beginning of the main
card Donald Trump walks in with Kid Rock
and Dana White and it's just like wow
how ecstatic was that crowd dude they
they they were wild and and uh they're
they're it's it's it's it's crazy like I
feel like in the past maybe it'd be like
a little bit mixed but the UFC I think
it's a good call for Donald Trump to be
showing up at UFC fights because it is
just
overwhelmingly in uh in favor of him
it's it's uh I believe that it's helping
him but in any case of course I have a k
I have a history with Kid Rock I made a
video one of the most viewed videos on
my main YouTube channel is called
celebrities I did cocaine with and
um haven't seen Kid Rock since like in
in all the in all these years and um and
I go to the bathroom you know we go to
the bathroom in like this special area
and and uh Kid Rock is in the bathroom
as I'm waiting to go into the bathroom
he comes out and I'm like yeah what's up
dude you know like I'm just excited
farthest thing from my mind is that
video and uh and he's like yo why'd you
do me like
that that's the first thing he said to
you yeah something I mean sound like
that he's just like yeah man like why
why' you do me like that and I was just
think like I I was I was stumped I was
like oh H he's like yeah I mean he was
he was by the way everything in the
video 100% true you know 100% true like
I don't have any issue with that but
like like but why why'd you do that you
know and I I wish that I could have that
uh that encounter to do over again
because uh the obvious answer is that
there was
no uh Revelation there you know like Kid
Rock's like singing about
enjoying you know like and and
furthermore there it was like I just
wish I would have said but bro like
there was no like Secrets Revealed and
it was the most glorious like epic like
celebration of rock stardom at the
highest level like I was I was just
couldn't imagine that you'd be bummed on
like how glorious of a story that was
you what year was that that was um it
was New Year's Eve
when
2003 turned into 2000 sorry 2004 turned
into 2005 19 years ago yeah yeah yeah
but in any case like uh it was it was
you know like we we went we stood there
and talked a little bit longer than that
I let him know that uh that I'm uh out
here in Tennessee he was stoked about
that he was like man I just like I'm
really just glad that you're doing well
he said really nice oh so it ended on a
good note yeah yeah it wasn't like it
wasn't like uh you know it was cool it
wasn't Kid Rock now has beef with st no
no no it was definitely not Kid Rock now
has beef and um he was just cool man and
and he he was like oh dude one thing has
really changed since uh since I saw you
last he goes now I'm
rich yeah I was like I was like actually
uh Kid Rock You Know actually Bob you
had that cover back
theno do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude